hi everyone
welcome to today's webinar move forward
with automation
i'm casey gansher from eppendorf north
america's manual liquid handling team
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event we are so excited you could join
us this morning
today's educational webinar is presented
by lab roots and brought to you by
eppendor
to learn more you can visit
eppendorf.com
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
throughout the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask the question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process
to obtain your credits i would now like
to present today's webinar speakers
paulina kassian and kirk mantion from
eppendorf north america's automated
liquid handling team
with that i'm now going to turn the
stage to paulina
thank you so much casey for the
introduction
so hi everyone thank you again for being
here today in this webinar
we're going to be talking about the
benefits of automation and how to decide
on a platform that is best fit for your
application
so why automation what are the true
benefits
of automating your workflow or even a
part of your workflow for that matter
as you may know most workflows in the
lab require you to handle different
types of liquids
with manual pipetting the largest source
of error is actually due to the person
holding the pipette in their hand the
operator accounts for 70
of the source of error with manual
pipetting
all the other factors listed such as the
actual pipette being used
and the type of liquid being transferred
additionally contribute to variability
with manual pipetting
operator error can be due to the
pipetting technique being used
which typically varies from user to user
and having distractions in the lab
which may cause mistakes while pipetting
when using a pipette in the lab
you may not be aware of the numerous
pipetting best practices
are you conscious of how far down you
are pipetting into the well of your
sample plate
in eppendorf's liquid handling guide the
proper pipetting technique is described
including optimal angle and immersion
depth when pipetting
scientists or lab technicians may
additionally have other priorities on
their mind
such as meetings to get to or working on
analyzing their
data when pipetting in the lab they may
also have distractions that could impact
the reproducibility and reliability of
their results
for example a lab technician may be
talking to a colleague in the lab
which would cause them to forget what
well they were actually pipetting into
so based on your experience pipetting in
the lab do you think you could get these
results manually
our automation platform the eppendorf ep
motion
tested the transfer of one microliter
using 40 different pipetting tools
you can see the amount of control of an
automated liquid handler
from one tool to the next the error bars
in the graph represent 10 transfers from
each individual pipetting tool
so we talked a bit about user error but
now let's dive into pipetting of
difficult liquids
based on your experience have you ever
seen droplets when trying to pipette a
troublesome liquid
if so what have you done manually to
ensure an accurate transfer
droplets form when liquids with a high
vapor pressure such as acetone and
ethanol
force liquid out of the tip these types
of liquids can be difficult to transfer
manually
one technique to reduce or even stop the
dripping
is to achieve a higher percentage of
humidity in the air cushion inside the
pipette
this is done by pre-wetting the pipette
tip a minimum
of three times which saturates the air
cushion
for an accurate transfer however
at very high concentrations pre-wetting
the pipette will not be enough
in this case it's best to use a positive
displacement pipette
positive displacement pipettes use tips
with an integrated piston
eliminating the risk of dripping
viscous liquids are another example of
challenging liquids
due to their thick consistency viscous
liquids do not flow well and tend to get
stuck in the tip of the pipet
your best option to combat this problem
is to pipette slowly
and wait for the liquid to dispense you
can optimize
your manual liquid handling by adjusting
pipetting speed
waiting for the liquid to move down
inside of the pipette tip
or by touching the pipette tip to the
edge of the well
many liquid transfers like this take
trial and error to ensure
accurate and precise results
similar techniques can be used on an
automated platform
to achieve accurate transfers especially
for successful miniaturization
in applications such as pcr or ngs
in the table shown there is a cd of 0.6
and relative inaccuracy of 1
when automating the transfer of 1
microliter 24 times
on the up and north ep motion the cv
for the transfer of 0.2 microliters is
at 1.8 percent
which is very precise liquid handling
this is the type of accuracy and
precision
you can expect with high quality
automation
now thinking back to the user is
manually pipetting
also limiting their productivity in the
lab
when pipetting the user may not have
time to focus on
anything other than transferring liquids
making tasks like data analysis
and additional research a second
priority
pipetting can be time consuming and
let's be honest
we also all have different
responsibilities outside of work
automation can increase your
productivity by helping you with routine
pipetting tasks that can
often be quite tedious depending on your
throughput needs
you may want to run 8 to 96 samples at a
time
the user can run a few samples or even
an entire month's worth of samples
while working at their desk keep in mind
that it's not always about
speed but overall productivity when
we're talking about the benefits
of automation
with increased throughput sample
traceability throughout your workflow
can also become difficult
automated systems can assist you by
providing
reliable data management such as liquid
transfer data
error logging and sample information
a good liquid handling platform should
either seamlessly integrate with a limb
system
or have the capability to export liquid
transfer data
the barcode on the consumable allows for
the complete traceability
of the tube or the plate containing your
sample
so now that we have discussed some of
the benefits of automation
let's dive into understanding your
choices and how to find the right level
of automation for you
so how sophisticated of a robot does
your lab
actually need
so what are the major concerns when it
comes to mind thinking about automation
what makes it so difficult to commit to
an automation platform
typically one of the biggest concerns is
the large learning curve
your thought process may be well i need
to learn a new language
will i need programming experience i
don't want to waste time
learning something i will never use you
probably start thinking about how much
time you want to put into learning the
software
of a new automation platform if it takes
too long to use
you may think it's better to run a
process by hand
automation can be scary software bugs
may come up that can make it difficult
to recover from
leaving you at a stopping point
i remember my first crash when i started
in automation
and it made me so nervous the
multi-channel head crashed into a box of
tips that the system didn't know about
the head was stuck and i needed to
somehow recover
and of course at this moment i was in
panic
but i decided i stopped the system i
reinitialized it and the head was no
longer stuck
so i was able to jog the head back into
a normal position
once i learned how to recover and avoid
such crashes i became
very comfortable with automation i can
understand the need to feel
confident to automate your protocol or
method
you want to be in control of the
protocol you were running
and in turn ensure you're getting the
results when you need them
it can also seem challenging to
transition from manual processes to
automation
not only do you have to think about
liquid transfers but also
about the deck configuration tip usage
and the details of all of your pipetting
steps including
volumes air gaps and flow rates
these concerns are realistic but
depending on the automation platform you
choose
they can be somewhat alleviated
an additional concern could be around
the level of software flexibility
your lab needs once a protocol is
finalized on your liquid handler
are you now locked into that protocol
are you able to make edits as needed
are you able to quickly write a new
method depending on the liquid handler
you choose it may be difficult to
optimize your process
you'll probably need to implement new
labware at some point that has to be
verified
on the system before using it in your
automated protocol
you'll also need to optimize your liquid
transfers and tip in reagent usage for
your application
for example in ngsb cleanups you may
want to
reuse tips for your ethanol washes and
mix
beads with your samples a certain number
of times before going onto the magnet
these are the types of optimizations
that you will probably want to do on
your own
we now discuss some dowel concerns which
are all important to keep in mind
when selecting a liquid handler that is
best fit for you
so how do you then go about choosing the
right platform
there are a few questions that can be
good to keep in mind
when considering automation these
questions can be used as a framework
to help you make an informed decision
the first thing to consider is your
sample throughput
so what is throughput and will your
throughput grow over
time throughput can be the number of
plates produced per week
or the number of samples run in a day
understanding
your level of throughput will help you
decide what liquid handler
is best fit for you the second thing to
consider
is the level of automation expertise in
your lab
if your team doesn't include automation
engineers or experts
your lab will probably need a
user-friendly software
turnover is inevitable making it very
likely
that a new person will need to be
trained on the system
taking it a step further how many people
will be using the system
the more people that will be using the
liquid handler in the lab
means more methods that need to be
written so
this means that it's extremely important
to think about the usability
of the software of the liquid handler
you are considering
another consideration when choosing an
automated liquid handler
is platform size lab bench space
is very important so how much are you
willing to give up
does the system need any additional
connections such as water
electric or air supply will this mean
you'll need to get in touch with
facilities
in order to get this liquid handler set
up in your lab
the feasibility of accessing these
additional connections
may alter the liquid handler that is
best fit for you
the final consideration is deciding on
how much of your process
should and can be automated
larger liquid handlers can typically
automate all steps
with additional device integration but
for example
is it a deal breaker for you to carry
your sample plates to a thermal cycler
or does your lab really need that
thermocycler on deck
that is definitely something to think
about
the level of integration and automation
that your lab needs
will influence your final automation
decision
now that we have reviewed what questions
to ask when choosing an automation
platform there are a few key topics that
i think you should remember
first the system should meet the needs
of flexibility
in terms of customization such as method
changes
and the use of different applications
the software should allow you to easily
adjust as needed
additionally if your lab requires full
walk-away capabilities
a liquid handler should be able to
integrate with devices
such as thermocyclers plate washers and
readers
depending on the automation platform you
choose there should be an appropriate
level
of of application support or expertise
once you have all of your questions
answered you should feel comfortable
on deciding what your automation
platform
should be for your lab
i will now be passing the stage to kirk
mantion
who will talk to you about what your
solution can look like
as well give you some examples of some
commonly automated methods
thank you paulina hi everybody thanks
for taking the time out of your day
today to
hear a little bit about automation and
what your automation solution could look
like
so paulina just spent a good amount of
time talking about the questions that
you need to ask
to decide on what kind of automation
solution you might use
so part of my job at eppendorf about
half of my time is spent helping people
choose the right automation platform
so depending on all those questions we
just posed you might have more questions
and that's where the automation
specialist would help
help you answer the rest of those
questions and then we'll be able to show
you what an easy
solution for your workflow might look
like
so casey and paulina were discussing
what automation
might look like for you and and what
kind of issues people have that
might make them resist trying to
automate so one of the things we come
across most of the time
is the lack of programming experience so
do they really need to know how to
write in a particular code for a
computer or
do they need some more information and
they had to
measure things and and program things so
a good automation system you don't need
any programming experience
you don't need any more experience than
being able to
use a computer whether it's windows or
mac based computer
so as long as you can do that a good
automation system should be
should be a good fit for you so what you
really need to understand is what you're
doing in the lab the science part of it
so we
leave the uh we'll leave the science to
the people in the lab and leave the
automation to
the people that make the automated
platform so if you understand what
you're doing by hand and
creating and setting up reactions
manually
the robot should be able to do what
you're doing by hand
so another another uh
resistance to automating that people
have is i don't want to convert all my
manual liquid handling steps
onto a robot it seems like it would be
very difficult to do
but what i'm here to tell you is that if
you have a good platform that it's easy
to use the software
you can simply tell the robot what
you're doing
step by step and transfer liquid from
point a to point b
because that's really all liquid
handlers doing the same thing you would
do that you would be doing by hand
you're transferring liquid from point a
to point b and we can all do that
i've i've talked to some of our sales
people
to show them like how to automate how to
automate how you would automate a
particular method
and sometimes the customers would give
us paper protocols
and say here's what i do on paper this
is what i do and this is our standard
operating procedure
and sometimes that's great because we
can just simply write step for step what
they do
but there's one uh person that we had a
sales person that we had would
say don't don't give me a piece of paper
just tell me tell me what you're doing
and i'll make the robot do what you're
doing by hand
so it should be that easy for you and
it's much easier when you just
have to tell somebody what what to do in
program and that's what automation
specialists do end up indoors
so the protocol changes should also be
easy
so if you want to for example i'm pipe
heading i'm pipating eight samples today
and tomorrow i want to do
96 samples those changes should be easy
and anyone in the lab should be able to
make those changes on the fly
and that's what a good automation system
should also have so what we're doing is
we're basically taking the pipet out of
your hands
and putting it into onto a robot and
you're free to do other tasks while the
robot is working with you
you're free to watch the robot if you
want i know a lot of people that when
they first get
systems they sit there and they watch
the robot because it's fascinating to
watch a robot do its thing
but we encourage you to do other things
in the lab besides watch the robot
this next slide is about the software
usability and
good liquid handlers as i was saying you
don't need to know
about coding you just want to tell it to
pipette from a to b
so these are some examples of the the
software on the ep motion
and there's on the top line there are
commands for liquid transfer and liquid
transfers are exactly that i want to
transfer
these 10 samples into those 20 wells or
i want to add
a bulk reagent across an entire plate so
or i want to dilute a sample or i want
to pull a sample into one tube
those are all things that if you've
worked in a laboratory you've used those
terms before
and the software uses those same terms
so it's pretty easy to understand
i've been with eppendor for three years
and i didn't have any automation
experience i came from molecular biology
lab
and for me it took me
about a week or two and i was able to
quickly
program methods and now i'm programming
methods for other people so
the learning curve is not that steep and
once you start doing it on your own
you'll find that you want to automate
everything that you've been doing in
your lab
the other commands on there that are
fairly straightforward to understand
are things that you do anyway in the lab
you want to mix by pipette or you want
to shake something or heat or cool
something
or wait at a particular step these are
all the other
auxiliary commands that that are offered
on most good liquid handlers
and they're just as easily as dragging
and dropping so to probe
to program these type of liquid handlers
it's just a matter of dragging and
dropping
the sequence of the commands that you
want
the other objection that a lot of people
have to automation is the flexibility of
a
of an automated liquid handler and
the eppendorf system is called an open
platform
and what that means is you can use many
different other manufacturers plates
and tubes and use them on the on the
same platform
so you can for example you have a bunch
of eppendorf plates and you run out
but you have a shell full of plates from
another manufacturer
you can quickly grab them and use them
on the platform and you don't need to
know anything about coating that
particular plate all you need to know is
what's the part number of that
particular plate the software has those
part numbers pre-loaded in it
and it's a matter of dragging and
dropping the new plate onto this virtual
work table
another good thing to look for in an
automated liquid handler is
how easy the software helps you out if
you're not familiar with programming
and you have you're new to the system
you want a software that can check for
logical errors
or alert you of possible crashes as
pauline was talking about she had that
crash
that the pipette tool didn't know that
there were tips on the deck and it
crashed
so some liquid handlers have the ability
to
scan the deck before you even start the
system it will scan and it'll look for
tips it'll count the tips
it'll look for the plates that you're
using it'll look and check the volume of
reagents
make sure you have the right amount of
reagents on there so that's another good
thing to look for when you're when
you're shopping around for liquid
handlers
you want to be able to minimize errors
right away and you want the software to
help you
program correctly the other thing that
we have
available would be verifying liquid
volumes
and as i said it can tell you you don't
have enough liquid on the deck so you
would know
to add more liquid for a particular
reagent
now i want to transition into a little
bit of besides the actual hardware
that a liquid handling company might
offer the support that they're
going to offer you we're spending a lot
of time saying yes these methods
and this this writing of methods are
easy and simple and anyone can do it
but we all know how limited we are in
time
so we do offer and good liquid handling
companies offer application support
and as you're shopping around and as
you're trying to automate a method
you should look for companies and kits
ask the kit manufacturer hey has anyone
automated the system
this kit before on any systems they more
than likely will have a list of the
systems that they've been automated on
already and successfully generated data
so that's another thing you want to look
for definitely ask the kit manufacturer
or ask the liquid handling manufacturer
have they automated it before that's a
great place to start
the other benefit of using application
support
besides shopping around and helping you
pick the right platform is once you do
decide on a platform
that they're going to be available
whether it's virtually
or coming on site to help you to
maximize the efficiency
of the of the robot to minimize the
consumable usage
and to get you started right away so
that
they'll come in program the method test
the method with you
train your train your staff and present
you with a user guide
after their visit is over so a user
guide is
great because you can incorporate that
into your standard operating procedure
and it makes it easy for other people in
the lab
to be able to use the system so you
might have more than one method you
might have 10 methods on a system
and that's important to be able to just
pull from a file and say this is how you
set up this particular method
so what we do at eppendorf is we provide
you with a user guide
after we come in and program a robot the
user guide has
everything on it that you would need to
just grab off the shelf
put it on the deck and it kind of makes
it plug and play
you you know how much volume of a
reagent to put on there you know which
which consumables to use and i like to
use the analogy
is if you had a lab tech parachute into
your lab and suddenly they've worked in
other labs before so they're familiar
with laboratory practices
they could grab the user guide grab the
grab the robot
and program it and get it up and running
with it without having
any uh learning curve or any time spent
figuring out what to do so that's one of
the great benefits of having application
support and a good user guide
so now i'm going to transition and talk
about some of the methods
that can be automated on liquid handlers
and these are just some
frequently used methods and most of the
time because i come from a molecular bio
background
i'm going to talk about some molecular
biological methods that we've frequently
automated
and as pauline is part of the talk she
talked about
all the benefits of automation whether
it's
the efficiency of it whether it's the
accuracy and precision
all these things tie into these methods
and why
these methods are great candidates for
automation
the first one we're going to bring up is
the preliminary chain reaction
whether it's going to be your
conventional pcr or your gel-based pcr
or your real-time pcr it's all the same
reaction setup right we're adding uh
we're adding our
master mixes to tubes we're adding our
templates to tubes
and we're bringing them to a
thermocycler so setting up conventional
or real-time pcr we have the same
challenges we've we've all gotten blank
gels
or no amplification curves and we go
back to the drawing board and figure out
what went wrong you know i have to now i
have to repeat an experiment
so automation is taking out one of the
variables
that variable being human error did i
make a mistake that i forget to add that
reagent
so we can take out one of those
variables that's one of the benefits of
automation the variables are reduced and
it makes it easier to troubleshoot
the next slide is a list of the issues
that we frequently run into while we're
setting up
a pcr we all know it's a highly
sensitive reaction so volume
differences make a huge difference in
the outcome
it's a tedious process we're we're
typically running
if we're doing real-time pcr we're
running reactions in triplicate or
quadruplicate
so there's many reactions that have to
get set up and
the bottom line is the bottom line here
it's expensive the reagents are
expensive and if you have to repeat an
experiment
now you're burning through reagents and
consumables we don't want to have to
repeat things we want to get it right
the first time
let's see here highly sensitive this is
an example of an amplification curve
and each one of these colored lines
represents a
quadruplicate reaction and this was set
up on an automated platform and you can
see
where these lines cross the threshold
are all very precise
so we want to have that precision and
this precision is over
six orders of magnitude so it shows you
that you automate it you can get highly
sensitive reactions and you can get them
reproducible
the next thing we've all tried to
pipette
i know i used to just do 96 well plates
but we're all trying to scale down
reactions as a 384 well plate
paulina talked about distractions in the
laboratory
i try to pipe head into well b1 and i
get tapped on the shoulder and it's my
pi asking me if i
if i have that data yet and i tell him
oh yes he'll be right with you and then
i look back at my plate and i say oh did
i add to b1 or did i have the b2
so if you have a robot doing this you
can talk to your pi
or you can talk to your colleagues and
the robot is doing the pipetting
so take that take that human error out
of the equation
so these are some of the solutions that
we offer we talked about
why automation is so good and i think
that
pcr is probably one of the best
illustrations of
how you can benefit from automation
so why wouldn't you want to automate pcr
is one of the best
best methods to illustrate it but you
pipette in the same well every time
you're going to have a reduced risk of
cross-contamination because of some of
the
controls that are provided by some of
the liquid handlers and
the tools you're not going to have drips
across the deck and it makes it easy to
miniaturize reactions you're not going
to
have to worry about that tedium of
miniaturized reactions
and it's going to show one more slide
with some data that was generated on an
automated liquid handler this is some
data that was generated on
an ep motion on the left of the slide
is the deck layout and this is just the
simplest reaction
we've done reactions with either 50
microliters or 10 microliters
and the jail pictures on the left show
you that
you get the same basic yield and same
brightness of the gel bands
when you're scaling down reactions show
you that the results are comparable
and reproducible whether you're doing it
by hand or on a liquid handler
the next method i want to talk about is
nucleic acid purification
again any molecular biology lab knows
that
isolating dna or rna is always the first
step in most
protocols and you always want to get
highly high quality
nucleic acids and make sure that the
sample handling is not introducing an
artifact it's probably one of the most
time consuming steps
in the process of getting your nucleic
acids
has the biggest risk of cross
contamination if you're working in 96
well plates or even if you're working in
individual tubes
you always run the risk of did i add to
that tube or did i change tips
was i supposed to change tips there so
the robot is going to be able to
to know what to do and as long as you
program it correctly
you're going to reduce the risk of
cross-contamination and you're also
going to be highly consistent
you're not going to make errors because
the robo as long as you program program
the robot correctly
errors will be minimized
so difficult pipetting steps is the next
side and
this is important whether you're using a
nucleic acid
preparation that requires a filter
column
or you're doing magnetic feed-based
nucleic acid prep
the pipetting height needs to be exact
and trying to do this by hand some
people have shaky hands
they might poke through the membrane of
a of a filter column
or you might slurp up some beads that
aren't supposed to be slurped up so
with an automated liquid handler you can
set that height
exactly and it's going to do the same
height every time so once you optimize
it
the method's locked in and it's not
going to change it's going to be
very very consistent
the next slide just shows an example of
on the left
is how easy it is to control an
automated liquid handler that has a
vacuum manifold
you just set your time of the vacuum and
the
pressure on the vacuum and most of the
time
kit manufacturers will have that number
already told to you and you just dial it
in
and test it with some water and make
sure that the timing is right and it
pulls the vacuum and pulls your sample
through in the right amount of time and
on the left we just have an illustration
of
a 96 place magnet with a 96 wheel plate
on it just pulling down some beads
you get that you get that nice ring and
you come in with your pipette tip
and you you can remove liquid in the
same spot every time
nucleic acid preparation on liquid
handlers
the good thing about it is on some
medium size or small size liquid hammers
you can run up to 96 samples at a time
you're definitely going to have the
reduced
risk of contamination and you're going
to get highly reproducible results
so one more slide with some
data this is some data from some a blood
isolation kit
that shows you that you can get
consistent
and pure nucleic acids automating it on
a liquid handler
and on the right it just shows you you
can put all your reagents on the deck
and you can be able to get everything
done at the same time
another thing that obviously most of the
world has been doing right now has been
rna isolation from viral material
and these methods have been routinely
automated on
many different liquid handlers from many
different companies around the world
for soros coveted two research for
obvious reasons so just to let you know
that this is being done
and it's being done very efficiently
right now
and the final method that i'm going to
talk about is next generation sequencing
and preparation of libraries for
nuclei for ngs so
it's very expensive process very tedious
very time consuming
and there are many steps involved it's
not terribly complicated it's
i like to say it's a simple method but
it's an elegant method
so all these steps have been worked out
for us
and kit manufacturers provide you with
everything you need to do all these
steps
from sample collection to library prep
to
quality control to sequencing each have
many different
sub methods and these sub methods might
be pcr
which we talked about before and we know
we can automate that
uh setting up normalization reaction uh
normalization
uh liquid handling that can be done on a
liquid handler
feed cleanups we showed you we can do it
from nucleic acid prep but you can also
do it for size selection of
of libraries so all these methods
or one of these methods or all of them
can be automated
on good liquid handlers so you don't
have to automate the whole thing but you
can automate the ones that are most
challenging to you or the ones that you
can
that you really want to automate you're
not locked in
so this is uh some example data from
what was formerly known as the nextera
flex
now known as the illumina dna prep kit
and this is one of the most common
methods that we've automated
this is a data set from a laboratory
that i worked
at in canada they were nice enough to
share the data with me
from their tape station just to show you
that you're getting the size and you're
getting
the right size selection and the right
purity without any
primer dimers anything like that
or some leftover material it looks
pure and clean
the next slide is just most of the time
before we automate anything
we can we want to do it by hand if you
can't do a method by hand
don't attempt to automate it so this is
what we'd like to do when i go into
somebody's laboratory and i automate a
method for them i'm always going to
compare it to what they got by hand
and this is from one of the eppendorf's
application notes
where we can we went in and did it
alongside
kit manufacturing partner and a
customer's laboratory
where we generated this real data set
and this just shows you
how close they are to being how close
together they are so
most people are very comfortable doing
things manually and are apprehensive
to automating them this shows you that
you automate this
this particular kit and you can get
comparable results
the same yield and the same call ability
and the summary for the ngs
is what we talked about anytime we talk
about automation a low failure rate
you don't want to reap you don't have to
redo reactions
you want to automate as many pipetting
steps as you can to take out that human
error
and you want it to be scalable and
consistent whether you're going to set
up eight libraries
or 88 libraries it should give you the
same results
every time
and to summarize everything we talked
about today
tips for successful automation and
selecting
the right automation platform you always
want to ask as many questions as you can
you want to know what application you're
doing
and know that if you're doing more than
one application
select a robot that can easily switch
between the two applications
there are many robots out there that
might just have
one type of application built in and you
don't have the flexibility
you want to look for something that's
flexible if you need that flexibility
you want to make sure that your all your
steps
are available to do whether it's heating
cooling and shaking you might want to do
things hands-on or you might want to do
on the robot
and automation is not always about speed
you might have a library prep that takes
you four hours by hand
it might take you four hours on the
robot
but that's four hours that you're not
spending
hovering over your samples you're doing
something else in the lab besides
pipetting
and always look for kits that
can easily be optimized sometimes kits
don't have
an exact match for automation and you
might have to adjust it
so bear in mind that you might have to
be flexible with
your with your concerns and flexible
with what you normally do because it
might not be a perfect fit all the time
so look for that and as long as you pick
the right
fit automation should be easy and it
shouldn't be any
shouldn't be any stress about it and now
we're gonna open up the floor to some
questions if
anyone has any questions i know you
could probably be putting them in the
chat
but uh casey will then moderate the
questions and hand them out to
paulina and myself thank you everybody
for your time
thanks uh kirk and paulina for both of
your informative presentations
as kirk mentioned we're now going to
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
so as we mentioned before if you have
any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the left
of your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we can with the time that
we have today
um so let's get started uh our first
question is uh
what volume ranges can the ep motion
pipette
i can answer that one casey so
the ap motion pipetting tools there's
four different tools
that span the range from 0.2 microliters
all the way up to 1ml
so we have another question how long
does it typically take
to get something automated
um yeah sure so i think this really
depends on the
automation platform you choose um
there's time that's needed for
installation
service and you need applications time
for training and protocol development
really this is where the usability of
the software
comes in and it's an important factor
in automating your methods and how
quickly and how easily
that can be done
great thank you paulina um so we have
another question here
how would you normalize your samples on
the ep motion
i would answer that one that one is a
frequently asked question that i get
and typically on the ep
motion you would need to create a csv
file so you can
make tables in excel excel spreadsheet
and import your
volumes and set a series of sample
transfer commands to do that
so if you wanted to for example
normalize your concentrations you have
to measure the concentrations first
whether you
set that up on the ev motion or not as
up to you but once you know the
concentrations
you then create two different tables one
with the
volume of the diluent and one with the
volumes of the
the uh stock solution that you want to
dilute and then import those two csv
files and the
system will generate all the sample
commands for you to do that
awesome thank you kirk um
another question what applications are
best suited for automation
yeah sure i could take this one um thank
you casey
automation is really suitable for a wide
variety of applications
um and typically these have repetitive
or
time-consuming steps or require accuracy
and precision
um and also better sample management
um so ngs is a good example um
you'll see a kind of a lot of automation
in that kind of world
because it tends to be a process that is
labor intensive and includes
multiple repetitive steps with the the
bead cleanup step so
thank you paulina um and another
question here
uh what kind of accessories are on an
automated platform
okay that's a fairly open question so
accessories when i think of accessories
i think of
not only the things that are can be
moved on and off of the deck
like for example the uh a 96 place
magnet would be a
be an accessory or you can have things
that are already
part of the deck like a a mixer or
heater or shaker
um some systems offer a little bit more
things than that like some systems might
offer
a thermal cycler on the deck some
systems might have a
a tip tower on the deck so depending on
what you want
there are some accessories that can be
removed from the deck and then there are
some accessories that are built into a
deck
so that depends on the system that
you're that you're looking at
but those are the type of things that we
consider accessories
awesome and i think you touched on this
earlier kirk but there was a question
that came through about
uh the minimum volume that the ep motion
can pipette
you want to touch on that all right so
the minimum volume that the ep motion
can handle is
0.2 microliters that's with our
tool that has a range from 0.2 to 10
micro ears
that make sense
one more question here is there a chance
of inaccuracy
with automation using a software and is
there a chance of malfunction with the
programming
right so um you know kind of like we
talked about earlier
i think with whatever automation
platform you choose there can always be
issues right
um i think in terms of the actual tool
it's important that you get it
calibrated and serviced um so that you
know you're
basically having accurate transfers
because usually the tools
whatever pipetting heads you might be
using
are calibrated before they come to you
so they should be quite accurate
um you could obviously always test in
house if
if at all you're like questioning the
accuracy
of the tool um and in terms of
also kind of you know if you're you have
the system for a long time
um you may have o-rings that fall off or
leaks or something that's not
functioning and then that would be a
service but typically
you should see um pretty accurate
transfers
and in terms of the software um
you know there you'll you'll you know
program like usual and put in the number
that you actually
want to transfer so that should be easy
to do and then
you shouldn't see any um issues on the
software side
awesome thank you paulina um so another
question
in the steps that require incubating at
high temperatures such as 65 degrees
um is there a possibility of sample loss
due to evaporation
how can one avoid this
that's a great question i can handle
that one so
on the ep motion i have a general rule
when i'm doing high temperature
incubation so i typically
anything above 40 degrees for longer
than 10 or 15 minutes
i would avoid evaporation by
adding mineral oil to the uh to the
sample
to prevent evaporation either that or if
it's a longer incubation on the ep
motion i would take it to a thermal
cycler
with a heated lid
much perks um can you
please specify the limitation of
eppendorf
ep motion compared with other solutions
yeah so i think i can answer this and
maybe kirk can uh
you can add on to this too but um you
know every type of liquid handler
is different based on you know what
you're looking for so this kind of goes
back
into what we talked to the very
beginning so um depending on
you know throughput is one of the really
big ones um
and ease of use and integration so if
you want
you know a system that can be extremely
high throughput
um and let's say have a 384-well
multi-channel head then that would be
um you know a different system than the
ep motion right
and also if you wanted to have a full
walk away of
integrated devices um that would also be
something different
um but keep in mind usually with
you know whatever you add on kind of to
that that the platforms do become also
more expensive right um and more
complicated i'll say
but yeah yeah that's one
yes i i agree with that i mean that's
one of the things about
the ep motion platform we're low to
medium throughput so
that's one of the limitations if you
wanted to do
more than a 96 well plate for
ngs that would be you know the upper
limit
for it for the uh ep motion platforms
uh the other thing would be the you're
limited in terms of like some of the
patterns that you can create with the
system so
when i was when i was hinting at before
during the talk was
you have to adapt your method to the
platform
so if you're used to pipetting across
rows rather than down a column
that would be a limitation of the ep
motion and that's just a matter of
reprogramming it and re resetting your
expectations
awesome thank you guys so much um we're
just rolling through questions here
we have a question that came in asking
if pcr
is a cost-effective method
a cost-effective method i can take that
as far as
on the to set it up on the to
to spend the money on an automated
liquid handler
yes i think it would be a cost effective
method especially if you're doing
higher amounts if you're doing that you
know if you're doing a 96 well played a
day then it's definitely
a cost effective way to to do it and
you're not going to use any more
reagents or consumables
on an automated platform than you are by
hand
i hope i answered that question in terms
of what you're asking hope that wasn't a
philosophical question
great thank you so much
so another question uh here as well in
software
usability what is the required
temperature um is there any required
temp for software
uh i'm not sure i understand this does
that mean
i'm going to take a stab at it anyway
require temperatures for
the operating the ambient conditions of
the laboratory
there is a you know a normal normal room
temperature would be the range
um that would be more of a question if
you
if we could uh i might be able to find
out more information about that
in terms of what our particular
eppendorf's particular liquid handling
platform
has been rated at as far as the
temperature and humidity that you can
operate the system in or the software in
that we could get back to you on that
one right yeah i think that's
that's a pretty good way of answering it
guys thank you so much another one um
how can accuracy and precision be
reached when it comes to automation
i can handle that one too uh how could
it be reached
just like you do it manually it's trial
and error
most of the time you we have a pretty
good idea of what
if what you're handling is something
that we've handled before
we have great settings that we can
provide to you and say this
use these settings for that particular
reagent
and then you would have to of course
try it in reality to see if it is
accurate and precise
right yeah i think it takes optimization
but then but you know
once you get it optimized and it's much
easier to do so
using the functions in the software then
you should be
once you're kind of set you should be
preset for whatever method you're
writing
your you have basically for accuracy and
precision yeah
right and that just speaks to the
mindset of automating things
you spend the time up front and get
everything
as good as you can get it up front i
don't want to say perfect but
you get it as close to perfect as you
can up front you spend that time up
front
so that once you're running something
routinely
you don't have to even think about it
just press play and let it go
awesome thank you so much and i think we
have time for one last question here
um can you use a liquid handler for
sterile
sample dilution
uh yes that's a with without uh
you would have to put it into a
biosafety cabinet or a laminar flow hood
but there are some solutions that are
offered to be able to do
sterile work but you definitely would
have to
have another manufacturer and obtain
something to put it in to make it
sterile
but we do have customers that do that do
that
thank you so much um i want to say thank
you again to paulina and kirk
um and do you guys have any final
comments for the audience
um just thank you so much you know for
everyone for for taking the time
and joining us today and we really hope
you enjoyed it
um and please send in any other
questions and
um we'll definitely get them answered to
you
yes i want to echo that sentiment thank
you very much for your time today and
thank you to lab roots for
providing us with the platform to do
this
all right thanks again paulina and kirk
for your time today
we would also like to thank labruts for
presenting today's webinar
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their
interesting questions any of the
questions we did not have time to answer
today will be addressed by the speakers
via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
both eppendorf and lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
we'd like to thank you again for joining
us today and we hope you have a great
rest of your week